aux sceptiques géante le fleuve s'étend
sur 300 kilomètres de sa source à son
embouchure et compte plus de 2000
installations industrielles réparties le
long de ses rives
l'eau est devenue noire parce que les
déchets liquides de l'usiné ne sont pas
filtrées
l'eau du site arômes irrite plus de 4000
rizières et fournit de l'eau potable à
25 millions de personnes
nous n'avons qu'un fleuve et c'est le
fleuve le plus polluées du monde
[Musique]
devenez
m
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur rt
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi
aujourd'hui est l'essentiel de
l'information avec nos invités en
plateau mais aussi nos reporters sur le
terrain tout de suite c'est les titres
de ce jeudi 13 février 2020 de nouvelles
avancées dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites selon edouard philippe
il recevait ce matin les partenaires
sociaux
le volet sur la pénibilité bloque encore
au niveau des syndicats
tout comme le chiffrage précis du coût
des mesures réclamées par le patronat
reprise la semaine prochaine des débats
à l'assemblée mais aussi de la
conférence de financement
tensions diplomatiques entre ankara et
moscou sur la situation en syrie mais le
dialogue n'est pas rompu
une délégation turque devrait se rendre
en russie dans les prochains jours le
principal enjeu sauver leur accord sur
un cessez le feu dans la région d'idlib
en proie à des combats violents depuis
le début du mois selon l'onu l'offensive
du gouvernement syrien ali ben a fait
plus de 800 mille déplacés depuis
décembre alors que l'épidémie de
coronavirus n'a pas encore atteint son
pic est l'inquiétude grandit sur son
impact économique la chine où le virus
fait le plus de ravages est en première
ligne est dans quelle mesure ce
coronavirus est il une menace pour le
reste de l'économie mondiale
peut-il provoquer une récession par quel
mécanisme
c'est ce que nous verrons tout à l'heure
dans l'édito échos de jacques sapir ce
sera le combat du siècle emmanuel macron
affiche son ambition écologique en
visite à la mer de glace en haute savoie
véritable symbole du réchauffement
climatique une opération de
communication et sans annonce nouvelle
pour l'opposition le président a
souhaité réaffirmer que sa stratégie est
compatible avec les progrès économiques
le ton est donné et ils virent au vert
[Musique]
tout juste privatisée la française des
jeux a de quoi pavoiser la progression
de son action dépasse déjà les 30%
depuis l'introduction en novembre
dernier
dans le même temps la mobilisation pour
un référendum sur la privatisation
d'aller ps stagne à seulement un mois de
la fin de la procédure est loin des 4 7
millions de soutien requis pour
déclencher le fameux rip le référendum
adp ou la chronique d'un échec annoncé
la privatisation est elle inéluctable ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30
[Musique]
et on débute avec la réforme des
retraites et cette nouvelle réunion ce
matin entre les syndicats et le patronat
rendez vous à matignon edouard philippe
n'était pas seul pour les accueillir
à ses côtés la ministre du travail mme
muriel pénicaud ainsi que les
secrétaires d'état aux retraites laurent
un petit travail ce qui est olivier du
soft pour la fonction publique
cette réunion précède la reprise des
débats à l'assemblée nationale et la
conférence de financement la semaine
prochaine écoutez justement le chef du
gouvernement
nous allons proposer après discussion
avec les organisations syndicales et
patronales un système plus respectueux
de la réalité des carrières de ceux qui
entreront dans le système universel dans
la fonction publique les droits acquis
jusqu'en 2025 seront intégralement
comptabilisées et convertis en points
sur la base des six vrais derniers mois
de la carrière de même dans le secteur
privé la retraite sera calculée par
référence aux 25 meilleures années sur
l'ensemble de la carrière
je parle bien de la transition vers ce
système futur et pas de ceux qui auront
effectué la totalité de leur carrière
dans le système futur pour les
fonctionnaires dont l'âge de départ à la
retraite sera à reculer du fait de la
réforme
nous avons retenu le mécanisme de
transition proposée par les
organisations syndicales
leur durée de service seront prises en
compte pour éviter les effets de seuil
brutaux la retraite progressive restera
ouverte à 60 ans dans le système
universel et elle sera rendue beaucoup
plus facile d'accès nous étendrons ce
dispositif à la fonction publique au
même âge soit 60 ans comme le
demandaient les organisations syndicales
de la fonction publique avec des
paramètres adaptée aux spécificités de
ce secteur et les dirigeants de la cgt
et de fo laurent berger y verrions
également réagi je vous propose de les
écouter
la cfdt elle elle a réaffirmé
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas de réforme
des retraites juste s'il n'y a pas une
prise en compte de la réparation pour
les salariés exposés à des pénibilités
et l'a redit aussi qu'il appartient au
gouvernement de prendre ses
responsabilités pour faire des choix et
donc peut-être ne pas faire plaisir à
tout le monde mais aller vers des
dispositifs dispositif
intègrent cette réparation et cette
possibilité de départ anticipé pour des
carrières des salariés exposés à ces
pénibilité du point de vue de force
ouvrière le problème les défaillances
que l'on constate au moment de la
retraite
en termes de niveau de pension de l'âge
de départ effectif pour une retraite
pleine et cetera n'était pas le produit
ou le fait du système de retraite actuel
mais bien celui de l'entrée dans le
système c'est-à-dire de l'emploi non
seulement la question de l'emploi des
seniors
mais également l'entrée dans l'emploi
des jeunes et les questions relatives au
niveau de salaire aux temps partiels
subis aux interruptions de carrière etc
et que c'était cela qu'il fallait avant
tout traiter avant de poser la question
d'une réforme éventuelle des systèmes de
retraite le retrait ou un référendum sur
la réforme des retraites voilà ce que
demande le parti communiste qui a tenu
tout à l'heure une conférence de presse
est lundi à l'assemblée nationale le pc
va déposer une motion référendaire
elle nécessite 58 députés signataires
elle permettra de demander au président
de la république de soumettre la réforme
des retraites au référendum écouter les
députés sénateurs communistes ont pour
stratégie d'abord d'expliquer d'
éclairer les français sur le contenu de
ce texte mais notre stratégie va être
aussi de demander au gouvernement au
président de la république de
d'organiser un référendum pour que le
peuple français et le dernier mot sur ce
texte de loi et c'est un moment
important de souveraineté nationale que
de permettre à nos concitoyens de
pouvoir exercer leur choix la démocratie
de pouvoir voter sur ce texte de loi au
final c'est une journée capitale parce
qu'il s'agit de concrétiser notre
initiative de déposer une motion
référendaire
c'est à dire d'avoir sur une feuille
les 58 signature un moment donné qui
nous permettront de déposer cette motion
sur le bureau de l'assemblée nationale
tout ça sera quoi qu'il en soit reculer
le débat et puis on passe par amendement
par amendement pour décortiquer pour
détricoter ce projet de loi et montre à
quel point des néfastes
et puis selon une récente enquête de
l'institut de sondages ifop deux
français sur trois sont pour
l'organisation d'un référendum sur la
réforme des retraites a parmi les
personnes interrogées les proches de la
france insoumises du pcf ainsi que du
rassemblement national sont les plus
favorables
seuls les sympathisants de la république
en marche ils sont majoritairement
hostiles en cas de référendum 56 %
voteraient contre le texte du
gouvernement
et pour en parler justement nous sommes
avec boris amaurose est syndicaliste cgt
alstom boris amoros bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour commencer peut-être une
réaction 2 français sur 3 pour un
référendum au sujet du projet de réforme
des retraites
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est clair
les les français ont compris qu'il ya un
sujet important depuis des mois voilà il
ya une mobilisation autour du sujet les
syndicats font beaucoup d'explications
dans les entreprises notamment
ils sont ils sont rendus compte les
salariés les français qui en guise ou
roche que c'est pas forcément très bon
pour leur avenir
à part peut-être pour certains marchés
financiers et que donc mais il faut
mettre ça réellement sur la place
publique et que tout le monde donne son
avis alors nouvelle ces réunions ce
matin de nouvelles avancées selon
edouard philippe est ce que vous
partagez ce constat non clairement non
aujourd'hui par exemple notamment ont
été abordé tous les sujets autour de la
pénibilité on va y venir effectivement
la cee il ya eu très peu d'avancé sur le
sujet le gouvernement à rester sur le
fait que la réforme doit se passer à
budget constant dans les cotisations
donc tout ça ça a le gouvernement n'a
rien donné sur la place sur la sur la
table qu'est ce qui bloque très
concrètement sur le sujet
habilité la pénibilité le le problème
c'est de de réellement prendre en compte
la toute toute les difficultés tout
l'endurance tout les pénibilités que
subissent les salariés au travail donc
l'ours qui lorsqu'ils ont fait toute une
carrière
ils vont être abîmée ils vont être usé
notamment bas sur certains postes en
fonction des travaux qui sont faits et
donc la pénibilité c'est prendre en
compte cette usure plusieurs de la vie
il faut avoir en tête aujourd'hui que si
l'espérance de vie augmente l'espérance
de vie en bonne santé diminue en france
l aide en moyenne de 63 ans pour un
homme 64 ans pour une femme ce qui est
très bas donc la pénibilité c'est
compensé la l'espérance de vie qui est
plus faible notamment pour tous les
ouvriers les employés qui portent des
charges qui subissent des produits
toxiques
justement est-ce que sur cette notion de
pénibilité très concrètement est ce que
les syndicats s'accordent avec le
gouvernement pour dire vas voir telle
fonction c'est un travail pénible tel
autre également est ce que vous êtes au
clair avec le gouvernement déjà sur la
notion de pénibilité
alors non aujourd'hui enfin il est clair
qu'on n'est pas d'accord le gouvernement
il y avait il ya quelques temps une
douzaine de critères de pénibilité qui
étaient définis sur demande du medef il
ya quatre critères qui ont été enlevés
un critère autour de porter des charges
un critère autour des produits chimiques
un critère autour des des vibrations et
inquiéter un quatrième critère tout ceci
enfin c'est clair lorsque l'on passe sa
journée à travailler en ayant des
vibrations en respirant des plus
qu'autre des produits chimiques
c'est clair que ce sont des critères qui
sont importants aujourd'hui le
gouvernement revient pas sur cette prise
en compte de ces critères là alors la
cfdt dénonce elle même un blocage sur le
patronat sur sur ce point de la
pénibilité est ce que c'est le cas c'est
quoi c'est un problème de coût alors il
y a le problème chez qui vend de la
prise en compte
qu'est-ce qu'on va considérer comme
qu'est ce qui est pénible qu est-ce qui
est pas pénible va y avoir
qu'est ce que ça donne qu'est ce que ça
apporte aujourd'hui en france apporte à
peu près rien de par la loi dans mon
entreprise on a un bon accord qui date
d'il ya quelques années
ou des personnes qui ont un travail
pénible on paf partir 18 mois avant
voilà mais ça c'est dit dans mon
entreprise alstom beaucoup d'entreprises
il n'y a strictement rien le troisième
point c'est qui va payer
au final on le sait c'est les salariés
passent et les salariés qui produisent
la richesse dans l'entreprise mais
est-ce que cet argent pour aller payer
le départ en anticiper des personnes qui
ont remplissent des critères de
pénibilité
est-ce que c'est payer à nouveau sur les
salaires des salariés
où est ce qu'on va le prendre sur les
bénéfices sur les dividendes des
entreprises
aujourd'hui voilà on a encore redonner
des milliards avec le cic aux grandes
entreprises et le gouvernement dit
toujours on ne touchera pas aux as que
les entreprises paient au déduction de
cotisations des entreprises aux abonde
aux abonnements qui leur sont donnés par
l'état
on ne touchera pas à ça donc là il ya un
énorme problème alors la possibilité de
partir en retraite avant l'âge légal de
62 ans pour les travailleurs exerçant
des métiers pénibles on vient d'en
parler est un point crucial pour le
premier syndicat français
comment régler cette question au fond
aujourd'hui alors c'est très clair pour
nous voilà la cgt il faut mettre en
place des critères de pénibilité bien
défini et qui soit applicable dans
toutes les entreprises précis avec des
critères d'exposition c'est à dire si on
si on a la pénibilité pendant une
semaine pendant un mois
derrière qu'est ce que ça va donner donc
on pense que un trimestre de cotisation
en moins de 1 qu un trimestre de
retraite plus tôt pour une année de
travail en pénibilité et qui pourrait
aller jusqu'à cinq ans voilà donc c'est
à dire pour des personnes qui ont une
carrière complètement en pénibilité
pouvoir partir cinq ans plus tôt je vous
rappelle nous pour nous la cgt la
retraite on la demande à 60 ans donc ça
veut dire un départ à 55 ans ce que nous
propose le gouvernement c'est un départ
au mieux à 64 ans voire même 65 66 67 et
avec un départ anticipé pour l'instant
qui est complètement indéterminée alors
le vice-président du medef patrick
martin à
jg lui un chiffrage précis des mesures
proposées est ce que vous le rejoignez
sur cette demande
alors nous sommes complètement d'accord
pour faire un chiffrage précis mesuré
sur nos propositions à nous sur les
propositions du gouvernement
ça ne nous intéresse pas vraiment elles
sont pas vraiment chiffrables elles sont
pas bonnes pour les salariés alors si le
gouvernement justement ne revoit pas sa
copie justement sur cette question de la
pénibilité
quel sera votre posture à la cgt
toujours en fait on va avoir une posture
enfin une position en de défense et
d'amélioration du statut des salariés
par exemple les conditions de pénibilité
qui sont reconnus dans certains métiers
par exemple ce qu'on appelle les régimes
spéciaux et il faut les étendre vers
certains métiers en fait on va continuer
à se battre pour ça ce que le
gouvernement veut faire veut faire sur
la pénibilité c'est met tout le monde à
la plus mauvaises conditions ou du moins
rapproché tout le monde de la plus
mauvaise condition nous on va continuer
à se battre pour que tous les
travailleurs qui subissent de la
pénibilité et qui donc ont une espérance
de vie plus réduite en bonne santé et
bien puisse aller vers ce mail ce mieux
disant merci beaucoup boris amoureuse
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes syndicaliste cgt
alstom je vous remercie
on en vient à la syrie sur le terrain la
situation reste tendue à elibou les
forces turques et syrienne s'affrontent
violemment depuis le début du mois
tension également sur le terrain
diplomatique qu'elle attire qui a
dénoncé le vote ce jeudi du parlement
syrien
reconnaissant comme génocide le massacre
d'environ un million et demi d'arméniens
entre 1915 et 1917
tension également entre ankara et moscou
la turquie accuse la russie d'appuyer
l'armée syrienne dans l'est bombardement
de zones civiles
le kremlin reproche aux turcs de ne pas
respecter leur accord sur un cessez le
feu dans la région
françois xavier lambert
chargé à ras bord cd kull prennent la
même direction celle qui leur permet de
fuir les combats qui s'intensifient dans
la province d'idlib
malgré plusieurs cessez le feu l'armée
de damas poursuit son offensive contre
les groupes djihadistes un contexte qui
contraint les habitants à s'exiler pour
survivre j'ai très peur que le
gouvernement n'avance sur ces zones
j'ai innée est apte à rêves ici les gens
sont tous des civils et des déplacés je
ne sais pas où je vais je fus les
bombardements la destruction les
criminels et le gouvernement
si les envahissent ma région je ne
pourrais pas vivre sous leur j si dieu
le veut ils disparaîtront que dieu donne
de la force aux autres pays contre eux
face à l'escaladé des tensions recep
tayyip erdogan accusé moscou de prendre
part à des attaques touchant des civils
dans la zone et le ministre turc de la
défense lance de nouvelles menaces
la force sera utilisée à idlib contre
ceux qui ne respectent pas le cessez le
feu
y compris les radicaux nous allons
envoyer des unités supplémentaires pour
rétablir le cessez le feu et nous
assurer qu'il va perdurer
de son côté la russie alliée de damas
continue d'appeler au calme
moscou racistes sur le respect des
accords de sotchi qui définissent des
zones de désescalade entre la turquie et
la syrie
en tout cas il ne s'agit pas de conflit
il s'agit du respect des accords de
sotchi et de toutes les obligations que
les parties se sont engagées à respecter
dans ce document par ailleurs il s'agit
là de respecter la lutte antiterroriste
menée par les forces armées syriennes
sur le territoire de leur pays des
négociations difficiles se poursuivent
entre moscou et ankara afin de préserver
les accords existants et rétablir le
calme de son côté le secrétaire général
de l'otan appelle à la fin des
bombardements sur la province d'idlib et
pour en parler
bigeard à cars avocat d'origine kurde de
turquie nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
millar a car bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation à l'horreur
pour commencer on le disait damas a donc
reconnu ce jeudi comme génocide le
massacre d'environ
million et demi d'arméniens entre 1915
et 1917 par l' empire ottoman
est ce que c'est un pied-de-nez à ankara
en pleine guerre de position contre
l'armée turque ihh selon dont je pense
que le terme est bien choisi c'est
effectivement tout à fait ça on sait que
ça relève purement du symbolique ce que
militairement les syriens ne peuvent pas
entreprendre vis-à-vis des forces
turques
eh bien on se contente effectivement
deux mots et 2 et de reconnaissance même
si c'est par le parlement donc c'est
quelque chose d'assez officiel parlement
syrien parlement d'un état qui au
demeurant est considéré comme
responsable de la mort de centaines de
milliers de victimes
sans compter les réfugiés donc
effectivement on peut parler de piège
alors hier le président turc recep
tayyip erdogan a menacé de phrases de
frapper partout la syrie en cas de
nouvelle attaque contre les forces
turques
est ce que cette reconnaissance cet
après-midi de damas peut accentuer
encore les violences dans la région
d'idlib
alors comme je viens de le dire la
position des syriens n'est pas vraiment
crédible je pense que ça relève encore
une fois du symbolique
il n'est absolument pas question à mon
sens pour les forces turques
en tout cas pour l'état turc de
d'attaqué ou en tout cas de développer
les frappes sur le territoire syrien
c'est pas le but de la manoeuvre
le but de la manoeuvre étant ce cette
volonté de contrôle de la zone
frontalière
parce que el al a des conséquences assez
graves pour le la turquie elle-même pour
combien de temps justement ces objectifs
de la turquie en syrie selon pour
combien de temps pardon cce de ses
objectifs de la turquie en syrie sur le
terrain de 2 de contrôler ces postes
d'observation je pense qu'il s'agit je
pense que la turquie se positionne pour
l'au delà c'est à dire que pour
la phase au delà de la guerre il s'agit
de mettre pression sur l'état syrien
pourrait également organiser la
reconstruction ou en tout cas affirmé sa
position et dire que la turquie fera ce
sera partie prenante lors de la
reconstruction du pays
et vous savez que la question des
réfugiés est particulièrement importante
voyez venir est un sujet très sensible
en turquie et il s'agit effectivement de
faire en sorte que les conditions soient
réunies pour que les 3,5 millions de
réfugiés puissent retourner dans des
conditions de sécurité acceptables dans
leur pays d'origine alors selon l'onu
justement l'offensive du gouvernement
syrien a fait plus de 800 mille déplacés
depuis décembre une nouvelle crise
humanitaire dans la région donc une
nouvelle crise des réfugiés selon vous
s'annonce alors sans doute on est
dans une période hivernale qui est assez
rude on est à un chiffre de 3 5 ou 6
millions de réfugiés en turquie
il s'agit d'un sujet extrêmement
sensible pour l'état turc et pour
l'opinion publique en turquie c'est
évidemment un point qui est extrêmement
important parce que l'état turc ne peut
pas faire face aujourd'hui un tel afflux
est tout l'enjeu est justement de faire
en sorte que cet afflux ne se présentent
pas aux portes de la turquie justement
c'est ce que demande l'opinion publique
en turquie également a très clairement
on a vu que lors d aider lors des
élections municipales il y a de cela
quelques mois c'était un enjeu
particulièrement important notamment
dans des villes dans des grandes villes
frontalières comme gaziantep ou adana et
même une ville relativement éloigné du
conflit qui est istanbul parce que très
clairement on a une opinion publique qui
même s'il a été très tolérants durant
les premières années de la guerre
aujourd'hui
elle est enfin c'est cette position
favorable s'essouffle très clairement et
on or aujourd'hui une opposition qui
devient assez flagrant c'est donc un
enjeu de politique intérieure alors pour
rester hyper doan complètement
complètement donc c'est effectivement
une un enjeu de politique intérieure
face à une opinion publique qui
aujourd'hui n'en peut plus parce que
c'est extrêmement difficile de gérer un
tel afflux de population d'autant plus
que la turquie n'a jamais connu ce
phénomène par le passé comme vous le
savez c'est un pays qui a longtemps été
un pays d'émigration et aujourd'hui elle
se découvre pays d'immigration qui est
voilà c'est une un moment
particulièrement délicat de son histoire
alors tension également entre ankara et
moscou pour autant le dialogue ne semble
pas rompu est-ce qu'ils vont pas revenir
selon vous à rétablir tout de même la
trêve dans la région d'idlib
alors si on regarde
si on regarde en arrière un peu ce qui
s'est passé dans les relations turco
russo on peut s'apercevoir
qu'effectivement il ya toujours une
recherche d'entente et je pense que
cette ce point concernant un point aussi
concentré que celui d'idlib sera
certainement résolue dans le cadre d'un
accord de cessez le feu puisque je pense
qu'il n'y aura pas d'autres d'autres
moyens de satisfaire les turcs et je
pense que constants compte tenu du
contexte assez délicat de la période
hivernale
ce n'est ni de l'intérêt des russes ni
de l'intérêt des syriens et de
l'intégrité de turcs que de voir un tel
afflux de population et les victimes qui
seraient toujours plus nombreuses
est ce que la médiation moscou peut
également éviter une escalade militaire
c'est votre damas et ankara alors la
médiation de moscou elle a été je dirais
assez permanente jusqu'à présent et sont
d'autres qu'elle qu'elle sera à
l'origine d'un accord sans doute très
prochain pour mettre fin à cet état de
tension militaire on est plus
effectivement à dans une étape où chacun
montre ses muscles mais on sait très
bien que les choses ne vont pas
davantage ce s'aggraver d'autant plus
qu' il est impossible pratiquement pour
les turcs que de viser des positions
ailleurs en syrie notamment sur la
capitale syrienne
alors la turquie membre de l'otan le
rappelle a reçu hier soir le soutien un
soutien verbal de l'alliance est ce que
la turquie espère plus qu'un soutien
verbal de l'otan selon vous je pense
qu'elle ne
qu'elle ne peut pas
quelques pas s'attendre à obtenir plus
qu'un simple soutien
c'est une position purement encore une
fois symboliques
la turquie est membre de l'otan donc en
réalité sur le théâtre des opérations en
syrie c'est la turquie qui est en
quelque sorte
adoubé qui en quelque sorte qui a le
titre pour intervenir au nom de l'otan
voilà alors l'union européenne a mis en
garde de son côté un affrontement entre
forces turques et forces russes
quel poids selon vous à l'union
européenne dans ce dossier aujourd'hui
force est de constater que le poids de
l'union européenne jusqu'à présent a été
assez léger pour ne pas dire inexistants
on sait très bien que les événements sur
place sont menées conjointement par
différents pays à savoir les trois
protagonistes que nous que nous avons
cités est ce qu'elle peut jouer un rôle
de médiation dans cette tension qui à
mon avis est de toute façon temporaire
je ne crois pas vraiment et on en est
encore une fois sur le terrain de
postures diplomatiques qu'on se doit
bien évidemment d'avoir puisque on se
contente de dire que la paix c'est
important et qu'il faut effectivement la
maintenir merci beaucoup
blizzard a car d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat d'origine kurde de turquie
merci à vous et dans quelques instants
ce sera les dites aux échos de jacques
sapir ce soir il s'intéresse au spectre
de la récession avec le coronavirus puis
nous reviendrons sur cette affaire à
d'espionnage au profit de la cia et du
renseignement ouest allemands pendant la
guerre froide
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes
mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
votre gouvernement et notre gouvernement
ainsi que tous les autres grands
gouvernements du monde savent ce qui va
se passer et quand ça va se passer a
battu mais ne voulons pas dit et ils ne
me l'ont pas dit m vous pouvez imaginer
quelque chose de si grands que la terre
faire ça cela va provoquer des
raz-de-marée des tremblements de terre
les éruptions
la terre va s'incliner ça va y perdre
c'est le colt de mon grand père personne
ne se soucierait des lois ou d'aller en
prison
illégalité prospérerait et la vie
deviendrait insupportable
[Musique]
on à construire
attention attention la tête mais qu'est
ce qui fait que nous allons découvrir le
meilleur de kerk on a construit ça doit
être bon
attention web on a construit et le bon
tu le vois oui il est en construction on
la construit avec six mois d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya les manches il ya les danish il a
les sintis et à les gitans dont on peut
voir on peut voir déjà que on a un souci
au niveau des des roms qui sont ni des
médias devra attendre les considérer
comme des étrangers et quand on est né
en france quoi c'est koné des étrangers
deux français sont le 15 août à jim
leech herria et dîners match ne nous
appelons tous canaris canaris signifie
région qui travaillent dur c'est entrer
dans l'armée ils ont abattu mon frère de
son froid dans ma tribu tard de sa
rivale entorse
coeur foie gras et les deux poumons
tous les gitans du monde je pense qu'on
est les plus détestés de toutes les
autres communautés un stage pour de vrai
que je pense qu'on devrait pas pourquoi
pas six ans qu'est ce qui pousse tout
simplement un apnéiste à vouloir
touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles web sur le podium
m6 d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans
un certain ordre et c'est un univers qui
nous permet justement d'aller encore
plus loin dans cet état d'introspection
et de travail sur le corps et aussi sur
les plus on va être dans l'instant
présent et on va être capable de gérer
ce qu'on en a à faire est de concentrer
sur ce que l'on fait dans cet état
confiance et la capacité à vivre
l'instant présent à être connectés que
sur ce qui se passe sur les sons sur le
toucher sur le ressenti et ça nous
pousse dans les retranchements à changer
des choses dans notre propre vie en
dehors de l'année
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france il est
20h30 heure française et tout de suite
c'est l'édito échos de jacques sapir
[Musique]
usines à l'arrêt paralysie du commerce
chute du trafic aérien et du tourisme
alors que l'épidémie due coronavirus n'a
pas encore atteint son pic
l'inquiétude grandit sur son impact
économique surtout en chine où le virus
fait des ravages
alors dans quelle mesure ce coronavirus
peut-il contaminer le reste de
l'économie mondiale porte-t-il les
germes d'une récession on voit cela tout
de suite avec quelle l'économiste
jacques sapir bienvenue jacques
merci olivier alors jacques faut-il
s'inquiéter des conséquences économiques
qui est de cette épidémie
eh bien oui parce que les différentes
informations que l'on a ne sont pas
effectivement réjouissante alors il faut
savoir que cette épidémie d'une
coronavirus elle va avoir des effets sur
l'économie mondiale et sur l'économie
chinoise en particulier à travers quatre
canaux le premier canal est celui de la
production
et c'est tout à fait normal la chine est
aujourd'hui le premier producteur
mondial et avec la chine il ya toute la
zone asie-pacifique l'accord et le
vietnam le japon
après il y à la question de la demande
évidemment quand on produit beaucoup on
consomme beaucoup de matières premières
et là aussi il risque d'y avoir des
perturbations importantes en particulier
sur les prix des matières premières une
3 un troisième canal qu'il faut aussi
regarder de près c'est la question du
transport aérien et du tourisme
et c'est particulièrement important en
france où on le sait les touristes
chinois qui ne sont pas très nombreux
mais qui met joue un rôle qui est
particulièrement important dans la
balance touristique française enfin le
quatrième canard c'est le canal bancaire
et on va voir aussi que la les
perturbations dans la production que ce
soit en demande où que ce soit en
production directe et bien vont avoir
des conséquences sur l'activité des
banques et des assurances alors avant
d'aller plus loin jacques je vous
propose de voir comment les français que
nous avons rencontré réagissent à ce
risque économique potentielle regarder
écouter tous les pays sont plus ou moins
touchés alors effectivement la chaîne et
plus
plus touchés parce que les russes est né
là bas mais je pense que le problème est
mondial la croissance mondiale et tiré
quand même par la croissance chinoise
donc on est tous concernés et c c'est
l'interdépendance des économies qui est
des gens qui vont plus travailler qui
sont obligés de rester en quarantaine
c'est chez eux les entreprises va
fonctionner j'ai des amis à pékin
également qu'ils sont quand on est chez
eux qu'ils peuvent sortir une fois par
semaine pour faire des courses
non non tout ça c'est dramatique pour
les galeries chinoises et voient qu'il
ya déjà des chaînes de production qui
sont arrêtés airbus a arrêté on épreuve
consommateurs de produits finis et plus
on s'est plus or un impact sur nous et
évidemment bat déjà 1 par rapport au
tourisme on a beaucoup de chinois qui
viennent nous visiter donc forcément
cela on les verra pas prendre un petit
moment sympa ça va marquer le pas un
petit peu pour l'hôtellerie et c'est
donc moi je pense que l'économie
française va souffrir un petit peu ça
dépendra de son impact petite récession
voire plus selon les impacts sur la
société sûre on va dire l'économie
générale vous le voyez déjà maintenant
en bourse sa remontée déjà tout le monde
attend que ça s'arrête et la chine elle
va rédémarrer beaucoup plus fort encore
on est dans une économie où on s'est mis
pieds poings liés avec avec l'économie
chinoise
tant mieux pour les chinois alors votre
réaction jackass convient d'entendre
bien oui on voit très bien que les
personnes interrogées ont évoqué à peu
près tous les problèmes qui se posent de
la production autour il et tous sont
conscients que ces événements même s'ils
sont pour l'instant largement cantonnée
en chine et bien auront une application
auront des conséquences sur l'économie
française
alors regardons le premier effet dont
vous avez parlé les arrêts de production
sont-ils significatif oui tout à fait et
là il faut bien voir que en fait on est
face à deux problèmes le premier
problème évidemment que ce sont les
arrêts de production c'est l'effet
direct parce qu'il ya aujourd'hui au
delà de one plus de 23 provinces qui
sont concernés et ses effets directs ils
touchent différents secteurs
l'électronique l'automobile
l'aéronautique la pharmacie alors pour
l'aéronautique en particulier on à
l'arrêt de la chaîne de production
deux airbus en chine ce qui a un impact
sur les sous-traitants d'airbus
c'est le cas de safran et sur
l'électronique
c'est évidemment l'arrêt ou le quasi
arrêt des usines foxconn et puis après
on a les effets indirects
ce sont les effets sur les
sous-traitants il faut savoir que la
chine produit énormément de pièces pour
d'autres pays ce qu'on appelle les
chaînes de valeur est aujourd'hui en
particulier dans l'automobile
ça a un effet tout à fait dramatique
l'industrie coréenne est d'ores et déjà
à l'arrêt et il y a des conséquences
extrêmement importantes sur les
industries françaises italiennes et
allemandes
alors on peut-on estimer réellement cet
impact oui alors on sait que l'épidémie
du sras en 2002 2003 avaient provoqué
une chute de 0,5 point du pipe mondiale
le sras était bien plus meurtrier que le
coronavirus mais ils étaient bien moins
contagieux or aujourd'hui ce qui pose
problème c'est évidemment cette
contagion qui amène le gouvernement
chinois à isoler des régions entières et
a demandé aux gens de rester chez eux
alors ce que l'on estime aujourd'hui
c'est que le coronavirus pourrait avoir
un impact au minimum d'un point de pib
dans le premier semestre il y à des
experts qui évoquent une possibilité de
deux points de pib en moins pour le
premier semestre
et du côté de la demande que va-t-il se
passer alors évidemment quand on produit
beaucoup ce qui est de la chine
on est un gros consommateur de matières
premières et la chute de la production
engendre la chute de la demande
on le voit sur la question des prix du
pétrole les prix du pétrole ont baissé
de pratiquement 20 % environ deux
semaines et demie trois semaines alors
ça une importance considérable pour les
producteurs en particulier les
producteurs américains
les petites sociétés américain qui
produisent essentiellement ce qu'on
appelle du pétrole de schiste qui se
retrouvent
avec des revenus très sévèrement
contracter ce qui dit sur le pétrole
peut s'étendre à déférente autres
matières premières qu'il s'agisse de
minerais ou qu'il s'agisse de matières
alimentaires alors jacques vous nous
avez montré l'impact de l'épidémie sur
la production et la demande dit y en at
il d'autres
bien sûr il y en ad'autres olivier et en
particulier sur la question du transport
aérien et du tourisme
alors il faut savoir qu'il y a l'année
dernière il y avait 2 4 millions de
visiteurs chinois sur 89 millions en
france vous voyez ça ne pèse pas très
lourd en nombre seulement comme ses
visiteurs chinois comme ces touristes
chinois ont un très fort pouvoir d'achat
ils consomment ils dépensent plus
exactement 1700 euros par visiteur alors
que la moyenne
elle est plutôt de l'ordre de 13 150 à
14 100 euros eh bien ça va avoir un
effet tout à fait important par exemple
si le nombre de visiteurs était divisé
par quatre ce qui est tout à fait
possible puisque aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus de flux de visiteurs venant de
chine sur la france et bien si le nombre
de visiteurs était divisé par quatre
dans l'année
cela se traduirait par une perte de 3
milliards d'euros pour le secteur du
tourisme
c'est considérable et s'est
considérablement plus par exemple que ce
qui avait coûté l'année dernière le
mouvement des gilets jaunes pour le
mouvement des chemises jaunes ont parlé
de quelques centaines de millions
d'euros 2 à 300 millions d'euros en coût
direct
là on est plutôt sur 3 milliards donc on
voit qu'il ya un poids qui est
considérable l'autre problème c'est
évident pour le transport aérien le
transport aérien souffre beaucoup de
cette crise
et si vous voulez une l'ensemble du
transport aérien qu'il s'agisse des vols
intérieurs des vols vers la chine des
vols venant de chine vers l'extérieur
bien on voit que cette cour est en train
de s'effondrer
en fait on sait qu'aujourd'hui il y à
70% des vols d'aérien intérieur qui ont
été arrêtés 56 % des vols à
l'international et le nom
deux compagnies qui cessent de desservir
la chine temporairement évidemment le
temps que dure cette épidémie ne cesse
de s'accroître donc là aussi il y aura
des conséquences extrêmement importante
alors jacques vous nous avez aussi parlé
en introduction d'un possible effet sur
les banques en quoi les activités
bancaires pourrait-elle être touché par
le coronavirus oui effectivement olivier
et il faut savoir que il y aura en
réalité potentiellement 2 et faire alors
le premier effet est liée à la chute de
la production les entreprises
s'endettent ce qui est tout à fait
normale en particulier pour
l'investissement mais avec cette chute
de la production
elles auront de grandes difficultés à
rembourser leur prêt tout simplement à
payer en fait les intérêts ce qui veut
dire que les banques auront moins de
recettes et puis d'un autre côté il y a
des grandes sociétés qui se sont assurés
en particulier depuis la crise du sras
qui se sont assurés contre le cas
d'épidémie c'est le cas de foxconn c'est
le cas d'airbus
donc cela veut dire que les assurances
qui sont maintenant intimement liés aux
banques seront amenés à devoir débourser
des sommes d'argent importantes
autrement dit le secteur de la banque et
de l'assurance va être coincé entre
d'une partie une baisse de revenus liés
à la chute de la production et d'un
autre côté des dépenses supplémentaires
qui sont liées à l'indemnisation des
usines à l'arrêt mais cette épidémie est
ce qu'elle peut provoquer une récession
mondiale ou une récession en france
alors oui c'est une question que l'on
peut poser il faut tout d'abord préciser
que cela dépendra beaucoup de la durée
de cette épidémie aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas si on va connaître le pic de
l'épidémie
d'ici la fin du mois de février et si
après cette épidémie va décliner
relativement rapidement il faut
l'espérer d'ailleurs compte tenu en
particulier des mesures extrêmement
sévère qu'a pris le gouvernement chinois
mais il n'est pas exclu non plus que
cette épidémie dure trois mois quatre
mois cinq mois dans ce cas évidemment
l'impact sur l'économie mondiale sera
très important
maintenant l'impact sur l'économie
française il est potentiellement
d'autant plus fort que l'économie
française va mal on sait que au dernier
trimestre de 2010 9
le pibe a diminué de 0 1% alors ça
pouvait être simplement un accident mais
si on se retrouve au premier ou au
deuxième trimestre de 2020 avec une
situation internationale qui est
évidemment détériorés par cette épidémie
avec aussi une baisse générale de la
production liée par le manque de deux
pièces de rechange
le manque si vous voulez de
sous-ensembles qui sont produits en
chine
eh bien oui on pourrait avoir une chute
importante de la production alors que la
croissance était estimé à 1,1 1,2 pour
cent à la fin de l'année dernière les
chiffres réels pourraient se situer
plutôt à 0 7%
c'est un mauvais résultat et il faut
ajouter que d'autres économies sont
aussi très vulnérables
l'allemagne bien entendu et l'italie
merci beaucoup jacques pour toutes ces
explications comme toujours très
instructive à très bientôt sur rt france
merci beaucoup olivier c'est une affaire
d'espionnage qui secoue la planète la
cia et le renseignement allemands
auraient pu espionner les clients d'une
société suisse créée par leurs soins
crypto championne du marché des outils
de cryptage un instrument d'une
efficacité redoutable qui leur a permis
d'accéder aux informations codées de 120
pays entre les années 1960 et 2010 voici
l'opération rubicon en images
[Musique]
vladimir poutine a tenu une conférence
de presse un mois après son discours
annuel devant l'assemblée fédérale le 15
janvier dernier le président russe avait
annoncé les grands axes de sa politique
pour l'année 2020
il avait annoncé de nouveaux critères
plus stricts pour les futurs candidats à
la présidence dès la prochaine élection
2024 vladimir poutine avait également
proposé plusieurs pistes pour réformer
la constitution ait des mesures
importantes concernant la politique
intérieure notamment sur le plan social
économique et judiciaire
ce qui me paraît le plus important c'est
que les gens vont participer directement
à la version de ses décisions
ce que tu as ta connerie c'est plus
important que la façon dont ça va être
énoncé les monnaies c'est que ces
amendements à la constitution c'est ce
que n'entre en vigueur qu'après
l'approbation libye c'est du peuple
il s'agit d'un les lycées c'est à dire
que précisément les citoyens de la
russie qui sont à l'origine en fait que
les auteurs de ces amendements puissent
les approuver
est ce que doit penser que le citoyen de
russie qui participent qui se faire
entendre sa voir est ce que le peuple
décidera c'est ce que nous déciderons
des cours de ce scrutin c'est voilà
est-ce que les gens et papouilles c'est
un moment où nos sites
c'est la pause à ce moment là
l'amendement sera introduit et pour
obtenir leur un journaliste écrivain et
spécialiste de la russie le chef du
kremlin prépare l'avenir du pays après
la fin de son mandat en 2024 ecoutez-le
eh bien je crois que vladimir poutine
essaye de préparer son départ
il s'est interdit de se présenter à un
nouveau mandat en 2024
il a aboli où il veut abolir un mot
déterminant dans le décompte des mandats
qu'un président russe peut accomplir
jusqu'à présent c'étaient deux mandats
consécutifs maintenance et demande à
point lui il en a fait quatre donc il
est disqualifié pour postuler pour un
5ème et je crois qu'il voulait le
marquer tout de suite quatre ans avant
l'élection qui aura lieu en 2024 de
manière à ce que les choses soient
claires pour la classe politique russe
et qu'il n'y ait qu'il ne soit pas sous
la pression de certains éléments qui lui
demanderaient de prolonger ce ses
mandats de changer la constitution pour
lui permettre de se présenter pour une
cinquième fois je crois qu'aujourd'hui
en russie
il y à une évolution qui est en train de
s'effectuer peu à peu très doucement et
que celui qui l'a initié dès son arrivée
au pouvoir l'an 2000 mais plus
particulièrement ces dernières années si
vladimir poutine il se considère comme
le garant d'une russie forte et d'une
russie en évolution vers plus de justice
sociale plus de démocratie plus 2 le
problème évidemment c'est que comme il
l'a dit lui même il ne restera pas au
pouvoir il n'y a pas vocation à rester
au pouvoir jusqu'à 120 ans donc il faut
qu'il prépare sa succession
mais surtout il faut qu'ils mettent en
place des institutions suffisamment
forte suffisamment adaptées pour que son
successeur puisse exercer son pouvoir de
la meilleure des manières goûter à
plusieurs reprises ces dernières
semaines le président poutine a indiqué
très clairement que la russie avait
besoin d'un pouvoir présidentiel fort
parce que c'est un pays immense avec des
contraintes qui sont très déterminante
et que donc il faut un pouvoir un centre
fort pouvoir présidentiel fort ça a été
son late motifs lors de la conférence
d'il ya un mois
de l'allocution d'il ya un mois c'est
son leitmotiv depuis et cela signifie et
il a dit lui-même que si on veut un
pouvoir présidentiel fort il s'agit
surtout pas de mettre au dessus du
président un autre pouvoir qui viendrait
le contredire donc il de ce point de vue
là il efface complètement l'hypothèse
selon laquelle il chercherait par un
biais quelconque à se placer au dessus
du futur président élu et ça je crois
que c'est très important pour lui il
insiste en permanence sur cela la guerre
pour le déploiement de la 5g et fait
rage entre les états unis et la chine
a new york les autorités américaines ont
annoncé de nouvelles accusations contre
le géant chinois de la technologie
huawei deux de ses filiales américaines
ont également été inculpés
washington accuse la société chinoise de
vol de secrets industriels
mardi déjà les états unis avaient une
nouvelle fois insisté auprès de leur
pays alliés pour exclure huawei du
développe du déploiement de la 5g à
l'argument avancé la protection des
données en cause la découverte des back
door des portes dérobées dans les
installations de l'équipementier chinois
cette technologie permettrait à huawei
ainsi qu'au gouvernement est d'espionner
les utilisateurs accusations
immédiatement rejetées par le géant
chinois et je vous propose d'écouter à
l'analyse de wali directeur général de
viaducs chine
cette affaire un peu bizarre parce que
ce recul incluse et c'est justement
celui qui écoute les autres
même leurs alliés on sait très bien ce
qui s'est passé avec la chute des
informations diffusées par snow tonnes
et sur le projet et prism on sait très
bien les 1/2 on n'est jamais arrêté de
écouter les autres
alors aujourd'hui c'est les avocats qui
a tenu son pari de le faire alors que
huawei et cette technologie et des biens
testés par des socialistes eux technique
les techniciens d'exemples qui maîtrise
la science ont testé et ils ont prouvé
que les travaux ne démontre aucune
faille technologique
donc je ne pense pas que l'accusation
désormais qu'à soi aussi cru par les
autres pays les états unis changent de
stratégie en afrique le pentagone
annoncé hier un premier ajustement de
ses forces dans la région avec le
rapatriement d'une unité de combat en
remplacement il y aura des instructeurs
chargés de former leurs collègues
africains contre les menaces terroristes
des missions de formation de conseil et
d'assistance
une présence également à destiné à mieux
concurrencer la chine et la russie sur
le continent africain et pour olivier et
yvelines ce turn auteur du livre les
veilles décisive de l'afrique
il est désormais temps que les africains
prennent leur destin
enfin écoutés actuellement on est dans
un monde de grands ensembles
il ya des grands il ya la chine ya la
russie l'inde l'europe et l'amérique
bien sûr et il était important que
l'afrique s'organise en tant qu'ensemble
ce qui est le cas et si après avoir été
moi même beaucoup en afrique
j étais déjà du temps du général de
gaulle au moment des indépendances
et puis j'y suis allé ensuite en raison
des fonctions ministérielles à
l'outre-mer et ensuite aux affaires
étrangères et à la coopération
je crois avoir été dans tous les pays
d'afrique et j'observe qu'à l'heure
actuelle c'est le continent du 21e
siècle qui apparaît pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que l'afrique
s'est organisée il ya non seulement
l'union africaine qui a pris beaucoup
d'ampleur qui va d'ailleurs créer une
zone de libre-échange cette année dans
toute l'afrique
il ya ensuite le fait que tous les
grands pays du monde investissent
aujourd'hui en afrique que ce soit la
chine la russie l'inde les états unis
l'europe tout le monde investi en
afrique parce que tous les responsables
du monde savent que l'afrique a un grand
avenir
le deuxième élément positif c'est le
fait que les revues les revenus
nationaux brut de chacun des pays
depuis plusieurs années mme en tout
augmente entre 5 et 10% chaque année
c'est quand même un par rapport au reste
du monde c'est à une progression qui est
significative
troisième élément
craon positif c'est le fait que la
jeunesse africaine est de plus en plus
mieux formés plus attachés à l'avenir du
continent est connecté aussi par
internet par les téléphones mobiles etc
en plus en plus et donc il ya là un
vivier extraordinaire dans un pays où la
jeunesse est nombreuse à partir du
moment où elles s'impliquent dans la vie
africaine de demain
c'est un atout moi je crois que les deux
les deux éléments sont complémentaires
c'est à dire que la france même si
certains le lui reproche est présente
est de plus en plus présentes au sahel
notre président emmanuel macron vient
d'envoyer 600 hommes de plus et ça je
crois que c'est important parce que si
on ne vint pas on n'arrive pas à vaincre
le terrorisme en afrique on n'arrivera
pas non plus à le vaincre ici en europe
mais je crois quand même temps si j'ose
dire il faut aussi que les africains
prennent au fur à mesure leur propre
défense en mains et ça ça ne peut pas se
faire du jour la main et dans quelques
instants nous parlerons des retraites le
flou persiste de député la république en
marche réclame un chiffrage sur les
impacts budgétaires de la réforme puis
nous reviendrons sur la visite d'
emmanuel macron sur la mer de glace
route savoie symbole de l'impact du
réchauffement climatique en france
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
il faudrait que les nations puissent se
regrouper notamment une troisième force
et c'est troisième force et l'europe
mais l'europe est incapable de faire ça
il ya une remise en cause de la relation
très privilégiée entre l'europe et les
étals et je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous
devrions développer un dialogue france
allemagne russie chez tous assassin ça
ça parait pas avancer dans le bon sens
quand même hein le risque pour nous
c'est de sortir de l'histoire
moi je suis convaincu que l'avenir des
relations internationales pour les 15
ans qui viennent c'est la relation entre
les etats-unis et la chine nous
européens si nous ne sommes pas capables
d'être le troisième pôle à ce moment là
on aura des fragilités et en sortir à
l'histoire
[Musique]
le 16 juin 1941
nous avions notre bal de fin d'études
c'est là que la guerre a éclaté
à
je faisais magasins étaient remplis de
victuailles énormément de produits de
vente et 1 est le lendemain la ville
était paralysée d'un disparu
toutes les étagères étaient vides au
mois de novembre
ils ont bombardé les entrepôts bada y
est ils les ont bombardées au point que
tout a été mélangée à la terre les gens
mangeaient cette terre mélangée au sucre
qui s'y trouvaient j'ai goûté mais
c'était pas mangeable
cette nuit là il est un bombardement
terrible et la maison où se trouvait la
bri a été entièrement détruit 10 blücher
tous les gens ont été ensevelis sous les
décombres
personne ne s'en est sorti vivant
non
m
[Musique]
l'amérique n'a jamais connu la grandeur
elle a été fondée sur un viol et un
meurtre nabe rien n'a changé nous
préparons donc nous mêmes la réponse aux
situations auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés
[Musique]
j'ai pas confiance en ce gouvernement
j'ai pas confiance en mon président j'ai
pas confiance dans ce système
vous avez une pièce bonne soirée les
gens ici sont différents ils sont là
pour différentes raisons
certains ont perdu leur boulot d'autres
leur logement nous sommes déjà la
capitale américaine pour le nombre de
meurtres inégal states mais nous sommes
aussi les premiers pour la dépendance à
l'héroïne pas d'être fini on peut rien y
faire à part survivre regarde regarde
c'est la jungle
on est dans une jungle nous avons été
amenés ici très bien vous ne pouvez pas
vous débarrassez nous nous ne partirons
pas nous n'allons pas mourir sans rien
dire
[Musique]
laissez moi vivre
gobelet je dois admettre avec regret que
le taux de suicide dans notre pays est
très élevé
[Musique]
il est monté je crois au 13e étage de
son immeuble et il a sauté un suicide
semblable a eu lieu trois jours plus
tard le 28 décembre
vous savez sans doute que d'après les
statistiques les gens se suicident y
majoritairement à 20 ans tron j'ai pensé
que ce serait bien que les jeunes sur le
point de se suicider viennent ici mené à
mana que pour voir ce qu'est la mort
pour comprendre l'importance de ce
qu'ils ont dans l'enclos en coco de niro
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'information il est 21h heure de paris
tout de suite c'est les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 13 février 2020
de nouvelles avancées dans le cadre de
la réforme des retraites selon edouard
philippe
il recevait ce matin les partenaires
sociaux le volet sur la pénibilité
bloque encore au niveau des syndicats
tout comme le chiffrage précis du coût
des mesures réclamées par le patronat
reprise la semaine prochaine des débats
à l'assemblée et reprise également de la
conférence de financement
[Musique]
ce sera le combat du siècle emmanuel
macron affiche son ambition écologique
en visite à la mer de glace en
haute-savoie véritable symbole du
réchauffement climatique
une opération de communication pour
l'opposition sans annonce nouvelle
le président a souhaité réaffirmer que
sa stratégie est compatible avec les
progrès économiques
le ton est donné et ils virent au vert
[Musique]
tout juste privatisée la française des
jeux a de quoi pavoiser la progression
de son action dépasse déjà les 30%
depuis l'introduction en novembre
dernier
dans le même temps la mobilisation pour
un référendum sur la privatisation
d'alépé stagne à seulement un mois de la
fin de la procédure est loin des 4 7
millions de soutien requis pour
déclencher le fameux rip le référendum
end à la dp ou la chronique d'un échec
annoncé la privatisation est elle
inéluctable
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face à
21h30
[Musique]
à quatre jours du début des discussions
à l'assemblée sur la réforme des
retraites le texte fait débat au sein
même de la majorité
edouard philippe a reçu une lettre lui
demandant des précisions sur le coût du
projet explications en images
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gabriel colletis professeur agrégé de
sciences économiques à l'université de
toulouse 1 gabriel colletis merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors pour
commencer comment comprendre la démarche
des deux députés de la majorité
mais je pense que les deux députés de la
majorité
en fait tu exprimes loto un certain
nombre d'interrogations que de très
nombreux français ont concernant cette
réforme des retraites
ces deux députés une pose des questions
qui sont des questions qui me semblait
extrêmement précises en matière de
compensation s'agissant à la fois du
travail de l'activité des retraites
futures de certaines professions
libérales
s'agissant des enseignants chercheurs ou
des enseignants en général
donc en fait on est confronté je dirais
à deux grandes séries de problèmes
un premier problème une première
question qui est globale comment cette
votre set
cette réforme est elle pensé dans son
financement global
et puis il ya une seconde catégorie de
questions qui concernent des professions
plus spécifiques comme les avocats les
enseignants chercheurs ou d'autres
d'autres professions donc ce que l'on
peut peut-être faire dans le débat c'est
peut-être ne pas tout de suite aller
vers des questions spécifiques mais tout
d'abord regardé l'équation globale et
après si vous voulez bien on ira vers
des questions plus peut-être avant on
peut noter un que ces deux députés sont
pas des moindres laurent saint martin
rapporteur de la commission des finances
est garant à ce titre de la
responsabilité budgétaire et puis
également emily carillon responsable du
groupe la république en marche
finalement est-ce qu'ils enfoncent pas
le clou après l'avis du conseil d'état
j'ai bien sûr il enfonce le clou mais il
enfonce le clou de manière particulière
c'est à dire qu'ils ne remettent pas en
cause la structure
global de la réforme mais il s'inquiète
des compensations de budgétaire si vous
préférez du coût budgétaire que vont
avoir un certain nombre de mesures
concernant des professions particulière
on pense bien sûr aux avocats avec le
jeudi un instant et aux professions
libérales
on pense aux enseignants aux enseignants
chercheurs mais là encore une fois il
s'agit de questions qui sont des
questions spécifiques
il ne remet pas en cause ses deux
députés ne remettra pas en cause
globalement la réforme de retraites le
principe d'une réforme à pointe par
exemple
alors on a encore un label à l'unité des
manuels macron comment est ce que vous
voyez cette démarche de ces deux gradés
de la république en marche est ce
qu'elles montrent un front désuni sur ce
dossier non je ne crois pas qu'ils aient
de front désuni je crois qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'interrogations que les
députés de certains députés de la
république en marche
eh bien on est ils ne font que refléter
les interrogations que tous les tous les
français on est encore une fois s'il ya
bien des questions qui sont des
questions spécifiques à certaines
professions parce que on veut et bien
passé un régime qui est un régime
universel et supprimer toutes les
régions plus les régimes spécifiques
il ya bien et quand même une
interrogation général que c'est de
débuter ne porte pas sur le bien-fondé
de la retraite elle même dans son
intégralité
alors vous le disiez au coeur des
interrogations des deux élus les impacts
budgétaires
d
des différentes
compensation pardonnez moi est-ce que
vous pouvez nous éclairer davantage le
flou persiste encore écoutez je pense
qu'il ya un certain flou sur la loi sur
les mesures générales
on ne sait pas exactement on a 100 sur
lequel sera la base de calcul de la
valeur du point
et ça ça intéresse absolument tout le
monde le gouvernement nous dit qu'il
faut créer un indicateur qui serait le
revenu d'activité moyen par tête des
français à cet indicateur n'existe pas
donc indexés finalement la valeur du
point sur un indicateur qui n'existe pas
c'est évidemment très très inquiétant
de la même manière que ce qui est très
inquiétant c'est le flou général sur ce
qu'on a pu appeler l'âge pivot ou sur
l'âge au delà duquel les biens il faudra
partir effectivement retraite
et là je voudrais juste rappeler une
chose c'est que dans la fourchette des
60 64 ans qui est très concerné bien
d'en parler retraite
le taux d'activité en france est très
bas il est de l'ordre de 33% si ce qui
me paraît être le plus grave
en d'autres termes les gens risquent
d'arriver à la retraite à 65 ans 66 ans
avec de nombreuses années qu'ils leur
manquent pour avoir une retraite à taux
plein donc on a des problèmes qui sont
des problèmes à caractère général qui
concerne toutes les professions et puis
après on a évidemment des problèmes qui
sont des problèmes spécifiques à
certains régimes
je suis enseignant chercheur à
l'université vous savez bien que les
enseignants chercheurs ont démontré dans
la carrière qui est relativement retardé
en raison de la longueur des études
on peut considérer qu'un ancien
chercheur entre ali nos cités entre 28
et 30 ans s'il doit travailler pendant
43 ans et bien ça veut dire simplement
qu'il va devoir travailler jusqu'à plus
de 70 ans pour avoir une retraite à taux
plein par ailleurs on sait que les
enseignants chercheurs et les
enseignants en général en france ont des
niveaux de salaires qui sont plus
faibles dans la moyenne de l'eau c'est
mieux et c'est dans cette perspective là
que le gouvernement envisage une
revalorisation des salaires mais cette
revalorisation du salaire at-elle
concerné des sols jeunes enseignants qui
ont
dans la profession ou bien tous les
enseignants là encore les choses sont
loin d'être fixé et on pourrait
continuer comme ça la liste très très
longtemps en prenant le cas des avocats
ou de l'ensemble des professions
libérales qui cherche à maintenir en
quelque sorte d'un système de retraite
parce que celui ci était bien équilibrée
il est bien gérée et ne veulent pas que
les réserves de leurs propres régimes
soient versées dans des dans l'ensemble
du territoire on voit bien qu'il ya deux
catégories de problèmes des problèmes
généraux dans le cadre desquels il ya
aussi les problèmes de pénibilité qui
ont été évoqués dans votre reportage
et puis des problèmes spécifiques à
certaines professions
au total ce que je voulais dire c'est
que là le débat me semble être un débat
d'une grande complexité
hélas au risque de voter finalement les
parlementaires risquent de mode et dans
des conditions de grande urgence avec
éventuellement à la clé 1 49 3 je pense
que c'est pas du tout comme ça qu'il
faut et bien posé la question devant la
représentation nationale il faut prendre
tout le temps nécessaire pour aller au
bout d'une réforme et doit être
consensuelle
évidemment ce qu'elle n'est pas
aujourd'hui alors la commission de
riscal retraites mises en échec
c'est tout de même à accorder sur une
règle d'or une trajectoire sur cinq ans
imposant l'équilibré du système
comment assurer l'équilibré sans
expliquer si il y à l'augmentation des
salaires s'il ya la baisse de la csg si
compensation est justement cette notion
d' équilibre et une leçon qui est
extrêmement de contestable parce que
quelle peut être la nature de l'
équilibre dans cinq ans ceci dépendra
énormément de rythme de croissance
économique dépendra du taux d'activité
des seniors dépendra de toute une série
de paramètres du taux de chômage
évidemment mais qui aujourd'hui sont
assez mal connue donc posé une règle
d'équilibré statique en quelque sorte à
5 ans me paraît quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile
tu crois que si la question des
retraites n'est pas uniquement une
question comptable
je pense que cette question doit être
posée en fonction de ce que on comprend
par activité de travail activité
salariée aujourd'hui on se
se privent avec des gens qui partent à
la retraite autrefois souvent d'ailleurs
au pré retraite et bien de gens qui
pourraient transmettre leurs compétences
transmettre leurs compétences aux jeunes
salariés ont plutôt que d'appréhender
uniquement la question des retraites
sous l'angle du financement ou sous un
angle comptable je peux comprendre
il faudrait qu'il y ait une réflexion
plus générale en france sur la question
des retraites sur la question du travail
sur les relations entre les travailleurs
les plus expérimentés et ceux qui
accèdent à l'entreprise c'est toute
cette problématique là qui est
évidemment problématique très riche une
problématique de société
il devrait être posée alors que là on
est en train de s'enfermer dans une dans
un débat de chiffres de compensation
budgétaire immédiate est évidemment
nécessaire mais qui est très loin d'être
suppléé justement c'est ce qui
permettrait peut-être du coup de sortir
du flou dans lequel nous sommes tous
parce que finalement il ya des modes de
calcul qui semble traduire parfois
l'amateurisme non une forme
d'amateurisme il ya une forme de de
précipitations je pense que le conseil
d'état quelque part 10 pouces le conseil
d'état dit arrêtons peu pose en opposant
nous tranquillement autour de la table
des bâtons c'est un sujet de société
extrêmement important qui engagera
d'avenir des français sur plusieurs
décennies
et là on recherche aller très très vite
à faire passer une réforme dans des
conditions qui sont ne sont pas de
bonnes conditions de discussion je crois
que l'attitude la plus sage serait comme
certaines fois sociales ont pu le
suggérer est bien de dire du bien
en effet on entend que l'avis du conseil
d'état on entend les réserves qui sont
exprimés y compris au sein de la
majorité
et puis on prend le temps de réfléchir
de manière plus large et pas simplement
du point de vue comptable
alors pour terminer on le disait la
conférence de financement débutera la
semaine prochaine
comment trouver 12 milliards d'euros
voire même plus sans retarder l'âge de
départ
je crois que des sons qui est en effet
extrêmement difficile mais on sait aussi
que que les régimes de retraite ont des
réserves qui sont des réserves
extrêmement importante donc le problème
n'est pas véritablement de trouver
de ne pas trouver les 12 milliards c'est
d'avoir une conception générale du
travail en france
avoir une conception générale de la
solidarité entre les personnes qui
travaillent et des systèmes les
personnes qui ont travaillé autrefois
donc un régime qui est en effet un
régime de solidarité
intergénérationnelle est ce que l'on
peut regretter avec la retraite à points
c'est qu'il individualise
considérablement la question des
retraites
il est dit aujourd'hui que les cadres
qui gagneront plus de trois fois le
salaire minimum est bien seront libres
de cotiser autrement et donc pourront
éventuellement affecter des sommes
qu'ils prévoient pour leur retraite à
des systèmes d'assurance privée qui
évidemment sont très loin les éloigner
des logiques de solidarité alors
peut-être certains de ce fait je ne sais
pas si tu un débat on voit bien que la
quantité d'eau des pas la complexité
débat est très grande et donc il faut
prendre le temps nécessaire et c'est ce
que je pense
veux le dire certains membres de la
majorité actuellement merci beaucoup
gabriel colletis d'avoir partagé votre
analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur agrégé de sciences
économiques à lille de toulouse 1
c'est une visite qui doit marquer le
virage politique du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron vers l'écologie c'est
le président de la république était
aujourd'hui à chamonix en haute-savoie
il s'est rendu sur le mont blanc pour
voir la mer de glace sur place emmanuel
macron n'a pas échappé aux manifestants
opposés à la réforme des retraites
mathilde romagnan au pied du mont-blanc
250 manifestants attendent emmanuel
macron pour protester contre la réforme
des retraites
les opposants au projet de loi veulent
montrer qu'ils sont toujours mobilisés
sa méthode rudd
ce qu'on va dire nous aujourd'hui change
quoi que ce soit simplement on veut
montrer qu'on est là qu'on lâche rapport
et que de toute façon quoi qu'il se
passe on sera toujours là on lâchera
jamais je suis venu aujourd'hui pour
deux raisons à la fois pour des raisons
sociales concernant les mouvements
sociaux qui se déroule en ce moment la
réforme des retraites et toutes les
réformes qui touchent pour moi la
solidarité et la société française en
général et aussi concernant la pollution
et les problèmes de pollution dans la
région visitée la mer de glace était
pourtant un choix hautement symbolique
pour parler d'écologie le glacier du
mont-blanc recul de 8 à 10 m par an il a
perdu 120 mètres d'épaisseur en un
siècle une illustration spectaculaire de
l'impact du réchauffement climatique en
france mer de glace 1910 2020 voilà
pourquoi nous nous battons
parmi les annonces du jour des mesures
de protection du mont blanc et le
lancement de l'office français de la
biodiversité
le président de la république multiplie
les formules chocs pour souligner
l'urgence de la situation sans toutefois
faire de nouvelles annonces ce sera le
combat
celui de notre capacité à inventer mais
nouvelle manière de vivre d'habiter de
faire
un mois des élections municipales ce
virage écologique des manuels macron
apparaît comme une opération de
communication aux yeux de l'opposition
macron à la montagne macron champions de
la terre macron l'écologie sur toutes
les chaînes et en même temps ces députés
européens votent un accord de
libre-échange climaticides avec le
vietnam et la france ne cesse
d'augmenter ses émissions de gaz à effet
de serre tartuffe maquereau en opération
de communication sur le mont blanc
contre les incivilités des touristes
fort bien mais quid de projet autoroute
inutiles entre thonon et âme à ce que le
préfet vient d'autoriser il ya quand la
fin des camions à travers les vallées
difficile pour le président de faire
passer les enjeux climatiques avant les
autres à quelques semaines d'élections
municipales dont la campagne pourrait
être dominée par les enjeux économiques
et sociaux et on en parle avec
françois-marie bréhon climatologues et
chercheur au laboratoire des sciences du
climat et de l'environnement
françois marie braillon merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors une visite
on le voyait de la mer de glace
tout un symbole effectivement mais est
ce que ce n'est pas un peu trop tard
selon vous c'est tout un symbole
effectivement je pense que la maire de
biot la division de laverda c'est
quelque chose qui permet de se rendre
compte vraiment des impacts du
changement climatique
même si c'est qu'un à côté spectaculaire
mais qui à mon avis n'est pas le côté le
plus grave pas du changement climatique
et de ses impacts chaud sur la france
maintenant c'est trop tard certainement
enfin il n'est jamais complètement trop
tard parce que oui c'est certainement
trop tard pour limiter le réchauffement
climatique à un vélo 5 degrés c'est
probablement trop tard pour limiter le
changement climatique à 2 degrés mais il
n'est pas trop tard quand même toute
façon pour pour faire quelque chose et
pour limiter ce changement climatique à
quelque chose qui soit soir encore
supportable pour les populations au
moins pour les publications françaises
donc non pour moi il est il n'est jamais
trop tard et je pense que la grande
difficulté en fait c'est de faire
accepter par une asso un certain nombre
de mesures qui seraient nécessaires
on critique très souvent les politiques
comme quoi il ne prendrait pas
suffisamment
deux mesures mais il ne faut pas oublier
que la grande difficulté c'est de faire
accepter les mesures qui devraient être
prises par la population vous souvenez
peut-être que le mouvement des yeux
gilet jaune qui avait débuté il ya un
peu plus d'un an a débuté parce que
justement il y avait une proposition
d'augmenter la taxe carbone alors la
taxe carbone c'est typiquement le genre
de choses qu'il faudrait faire pour
limiter le changement climatique alors
vous parlez en à fond de la mer de glace
comme n'étant pas l'impact le plus grave
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus grave pour
vous aujourd'hui on va vous avez vu les
canicules qu'on a eu c'est à dire année
qui sont de plus en plus intense par
exemple qui sont de plus en plus
difficile à supporter alors elles
peuvent être supportable parle par les
humains parce que on peut se réfugier on
peut utiliser la climatisation mais il
faut bien se penser que pour la
biosphère qui n'a pas les mêmes
ressources
ça peut être vraiment dramatique donc il
ya eu il peut y avoir des impacts
extrêmement important point pour la
biosphère en particulier leur disent
qu'il ya des sécheresses il y avait des
forêts entières qui risque de
disparaître parce qu'elles ne seront
plus adaptés au nouveau climat
et puis aussi des écosystèmes de manière
générale qui qui ne pourront pas
s'adapter au réchauffement climatique
vous vous souvenez il ya quelques
semaines on a eu les des exemples des
feux en australie qui était extrêmement
important donc là aussi c'est le
peut-être des forêts entières qui vont
disparaître et des écosystèmes généraux
qui vont disparaître plusieurs régions
du monde
et puis moi je bon la france a
finalement à certaines ressources pour
s'adapter à ce changement climatique
mais je pense que c'est important de
penser à d'autres pays s'ils n'aiment
pas les mêmes ressources et pour
laquelle typiquement la production
agricole
idriss ne pas être suffisante pour
nourrir les populations du fait de ce
changement alors c'est quoi la solution
il faudrait d'abord respecter les
accords de paris est bien la solution
c'est de prendre un grand nombre de
mesures pour diminuer la consommation
des combustibles fossiles
donc ça veut dire partir sur la sobriété
c'est à dire la sobriété ça veut dire
avoir des faire moins de kilomètres en
train en avion ou en voiture à voir
les logements qu'ils soient plus faibles
éventuellement jouer sur la démographie
on peut il faut travailler sur la
technologie ça veut dire isoler les
bâtiments de mieux que ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui développer des moteurs
qu'ils soient plus efficaces
et puis le dernier show c'est
l'électrification peut penser un certain
nombre de choses ou si on a une
électricité peu carbonée on peut penser
à se chauffer à l'électrique plutôt
qu'au gaz on peut penser à des voitures
électriques plutôt que des voitures à
essence ou mais de manière générale
développer les transports les transports
en commun est plutôt les transports en
commun électrique alors le sait tout ça
excusez moi mais tout ça c'est difficile
à faire accepter par la pop culture
parce que ça veut dire éventuellement
une diminution du niveau de vie alors le
6 février selon un sondage hélas pour
les échos radio crache la radio
classique et l'institut montaigne
les français sont 66 % à estimer que le
gouvernement n'en fait pas assez pour
contrer le dérèglement du climat
en même temps ils sont 59% a jugé
inutile la convention citoyenne dont les
travaux s'achèveront en avril la
dimension verte de l'acte 2 du président
macron est-ce qu'elles échappent
complètement aux français selon vous et
si oui pourquoi je pose que c'est ya il
ya un vrai désir d'écologie de paix de
la part de la population française
enfin c'est ce que je ressens j'ai
l'impression en tout cas c'est ce que
semblent ressentir tous les hommes
politiques parce que tous les hommes
politiques ont tendance à verdir leurs
programmes pour essayer pour espérer
être élu est-ce que c'est sincère je
pose à nouveau que le président mâcon a
effectivement compris le danger du
réchauffement climatique et je pense
qu'il a effectivement compris qu'il
fallait faire quelque chose de manière
assez urgente mais à nouveau il est pris
en tenaille entre cet objectif-là de
limiter nos émissions de carbone
et puis d'autres objectifs qui sont bas
il faut quand même assurer une certaine
croissance à la france
enfin roanne à l'économie française pour
que le chômage continue à diminuer et
que les gens se sortent bien donc la
difficulté et la date
t l'écologie voudrais qu'on aille vers
une société plus fort mais donne côté là
les puissances économiques et puis tu
mets même la volonté des gens est
incompatible avec eux cette direction
alors pour certains les politiques
s'emparent de l'écologie pour faire des
coups politiques
justement qu'est ce que vous en pensez y
à de la vraie sincérité aujourd'hui
quand on parle de réchauffement
climatique
oui que je suis comme je le disais je
pense qu'il ya une vraie sincérité je
suis à peu près persuadé que le
prévision de nacre on a bien compris la
gravité du problème maintenant est ce
que il le joue là dessus pour essayer de
se donner une image favorable
je pense que c'est vrai aussi et alors
je moi je constate que à peu près tous
les hommes politiques jouent de ça et
annonce des grandes ambitions
écologiques c'est pas propre aux
prévisions macro il faut j'ai
l'impression qu'ils font tous un peu ça
et est-ce que c'est sincère c'est
probablement sincère dans une certaine
mesure mais probablement pas
complètement non plus mais est ce que
justement vous attendez des actions
fortes des actions beaucoup plus forte
plus que des actions symboliques
aujourd'hui de la part du politique pour
inverser la vapeur oui moi j'aimerais
bien qu'il ya des vrais des vraies
mesures qui soient prises et
éventuellement des mesures qui seront
pas du tout consensuel d'ailleurs à
titre personnel lors de la alors à titre
personnel maintenant c'est pas quelque
chose qui est porté par tout le monde
mais je voudrais qu'on lance dès
aujourd'hui un gros crawl programme de
développement du nucléaire en france de
manière à ce qu'on puisse remplacer le
chauffage au gaz ou au fioul par du
chauffage électrique sous forme de
pompes à chaleur pour qu'on puisse te
vas avoir vraiment un gros programme
d'électrification des transports et donc
pour tout ça il faut une électricité
abondante et non carbonées et donc je à
titre personnel je pense que ça passe
nécessairement par une le développement
du nucléaire ce qui est totalement
contraire avec la fermeture de la
centrale de fessenheim qui va avoir lieu
dans
une dizaine de jours maintenant
justement ce que vous nous dites c'est
le nucléaire c'est écolo c'est ça au
fond aujourd'hui que le message que vous
passez c'est moi je pense
qu'effectivement le nucléaire et d'écolo
alors il n'y a aucune source d'énergie
qui est totalement propre mais parmi les
sources d'énergie c'est effectivement la
plus proche alors pour terminer une
dernière question est-ce que selon vous
la prise de conscience écologique va se
lire dans les résultats des prochaines
élections municipales
eh bien je l'espère on va dire on va
dire que je pense que ce serait bien que
il ya effectivement un message de la
population qui démontre que la poule est
souvent effectivement les des objectifs
écologiques au sérieux et que c'est à
motifs et de de votre pas tant il
faudrait que la population accepte aussi
les mesures écologiques qui sont
nécessaires merci beaucoup
françois-marie bréhon d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
climatologues et chercheur au
laboratoire des sciences et du climat et
de l'environnement
je remercie et dans quelques instants un
autre débat sur la privatisation après
les bons chiffres publiés par la
française des jeux qui a vu son action
dépasse et déjà les 30% depuis
l'introduction en bourse en novembre
dernier quand aéroports de paris cette
privatisation et à l'inéluctable eh bien
nous en débattrons avec nos invités à
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
nada coup ils disent que personne n'a
jamais parcouru une telle distance
l'italien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est oublier quelle étape
sert ce n'est pas un record guinness
pour rien dès les gens et les chiens
travail jusqu'aux limites de leurs
capacités
[Musique]
chose qu'on sent que les chiens sont
très fatigués des moi aussi je suis
épuisé
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
pour les autres les ont aidés c'était
nos voisins la nuit d'un million de
personnes sont mortes hyde
[Musique]
ils ont tué une personne avec leurs
familles rif des bébés
[Musique]
non il n'ya plus d'eau autour de tout ce
qu elle tout le monde et juan m c'est
tout
[Musique]
il creuse le sol pour me trouver
les uns y at il quelqu'un ici sortez
c'est un travail dangereux oui même les
enfants travaillent pour en extraire et
ses parents et ça c'est cali à damas
[Musique]
et frotter votre mag irak
c'est pourtant leur seul moyen de survie
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre
trois mois après sa privatisation la
française des jeux affiche une belle
santé économique de quoi revoir ses
perspectives à la hausse pour 2020
retour sur les résultats de 2010 9 en
images
[Musique]
oh
un an
coût
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et puis le bras de fer entre le
gouvernement et les opposants à la
privatisation du groupe adp se poursuit
alors que l'état souhaite privatiser le
groupe aéroportuaire français la
pétition pour un référendum d'initiative
populaire ni scié hâtive populaire est
loin d'avoir récolté des voix
nécessaires les précisions il y en a
fait radiant 1 millions 35 1528 voir
voici au dernier comptage le nombre de
signatures enregistrées en faveur du
projet de référendum d'initiative
partagée
le rip lancé en mai dernier une pétition
initiée par les opposants à la
privatisation du groupe adp aéroports de
paris prévu par le gouvernement
si la procédure en ligne est ouverte
jusqu'au mois prochain
le projet est donc loin d'avoir
rassemblé toutes les voies espérait 4
millions le seuil nécessaire pour que
soit validé la proposition de loi
référendaire
par ailleurs la demande de certains
parlementaires d'organiser un débat
public a été jugée irrecevable en l'état
cette semaine faute d'un cahier des
charges publié officiellement un nouveau
coup dur pour les 250 parlementaires
hostiles à la privatisation des
aéroports de paris qui dénonce le manque
d'informations à ce sujet il n'est pas
normal que les français soient aussi peu
informés sur les conséquences d'une
éventuelle privatisation d'adé paix là
où le gouvernement souhaite passer entre
les gouttes
nous souhaitons un large débat qui
permettra à chacun de comprendre ce à
quoi ils s'exposent dans les grandes
lignes les opposants au projet défendre
surtout adp comme une propriété publique
un bien commun qui rapporterait à l'état
et donc aux français
près de 200 millions d'euros de
dividendes chaque année
mais au delà du côté économique l'enjeu
serait aussi stratégique pour le
tourisme et l'écologie en france
de son côté le gouvernement reste pour
le moment muet rien ne dit que la
privatisation du géant aéroportuaire ira
à son terme
et c'est donc l'heure de notre face à
face la fdj est ainsi que adp on en
parle tout de suite avec nos invités
c'est l'heure de notre face à face
[Musique]
donc tout juste privatisée la française
des jeux a donc de quoi se pavoiser on
va reparler tout de suite avec dominique
philias vous êtes ex chargé de
communication responsable syndical sud
aérien à vos côtés fergane asie arrive
en tête chargé d'études pour l'institut
de recherches économiques et fiscales
bonsoir à tous les deux alors on vient
de voir après trois mois après sa
privatisation fdj se porte plutôt très
bien une bonne nouvelle donc pour les
cinq cent mille français qui ont investi
dans la vie j'ai du coup est ce que ses
résultats au fond ils appuient le fait
qu'il fallait privatiser fdj selon vous
les tendances japonais - dévié
qu'aéroports de paris je m'exprimerai
plus facilement peut-être sur la partie
hier au point sur la fdj ensuite on
enchaînera sur i alors de pour la fdj
n'y avait aucune raison pour que cette
privatisation se passe mal en soi même
si il faut quand même avouer qu'ils
aient un petit peu de tricher concernant
la fdj puisque cette société à garder
son monopole
idéalement il faudrait ouvrir ses
activités à la concurrence c'est à dire
qu'il n'ya pas de raison pour que un
nouvel entrant ne puisse pas offrir des
jeux de meilleure qualité que la fdj
donc là dessus il ya peut-être encore
une barrière à faire sauter pour avoir
une économie de marché
authentique concurrentiel et nous
distordus par des privilèges
gouvernementaux ceci dit le fait que les
français se soient massivement à
intéresser à cette privatisation en
investissant est le signe que cette
climatisation a plutôt bien été
accueillies
il n'y avait aucune raison que les
choses puissent mal tourné donc c'est
cet heureux que ce soit finalement une
opération réussie
un succès politique vous le voyez comme
un succès politique même si vous
connaissez pas très bien le le sujet
comme vous en fait je dirais que c'est
un certainement un succès pour le
gouvernement actuel puisque c'était dans
leurs intentions pour moi un aux portes
de paris enfin le groupe aéroports de
paris la fdj ce sont vraiment deux
entités totalement opposé peut-être que
pour l'une la justification est plus
acceptable que pour l'autre en ce qui
concerne le groupe aéroports de paris
les métiers des aéroports les
conséquences je suis beaucoup moins
comment dirais-je pour la vente
de la majorité du gouvernement puisque
aéroports de paris est déjà privatisés
c'est un terme qui n'est pas adéquat
adp est une société anonyme depuis bien
longtemps c'est vrai que l'état à 50
plus de 50 pour ça donc la majorité et
l'état devraient regarder si c'était
idéal la minorité de blocage de manière
à pouvoir garder le pouvoir de décision
mais pourquoi vendre pourquoi vendre en
fait que financièrement
de l'argent qui à un moment donné
appartenu au public d'une part et
pourquoi vendre avant la prochaine coupe
du monde de rugby est avant les
prochains jeux olympiques qui eux aussi
vont être une manne financière et
rapporter énormément dans les deux trois
ans à venir
finalement effectivement pourquoi vendre
aéroports de paris puisque c'est un bien
commun qui finalement rapporte de
l'argent
aujourd'hui ferghana syrie c'est
toujours très drôle en france de
constater qu'on est tellement est atys
tellement colbertiste que même lorsqu'on
envisage une privatisation
on se demande toujours si c'est bon ou
non pour l'état mais ce n'est pas le
véritable enjeu d'une privatisation ce
n'est pas là la problématique principale
lorsque les pays du bloc de l'est
lorsque les pays communiste après la
chute du mur de berlin ont commencé à
privatiser leurs industries en masse ils
ne sont pas demandé si c'était bon ou
non pour l'état n'était pas la question
ils ont privatisé leur industrie parce
qu'il considérait à juste titre que en
privatisant c'est à dire en soumettant
les parties prenantes à des logiques de
marché des industries serait plus
productif plus innovantes plus
compétitif en sachant pertinemment que
c'est bien la compétitivité la
productivité d'une économie qui
conditionne la prospérité d'une
civilisation
donc la question qui devrait nous
occuper pour l'aéroport de paris c'est
quelles sont les conditions dans
lesquelles on offre le plus d'incitation
à la bonne gestion une gestion innovante
la plus productive possible la plus
dynamique possible s en confiant en
aéroport à des décideurs politiques à
des politiciens à des hauts
fonctionnaires
les revenus et les patrimoines sont
complètement décorrélé de leur
performance ou est ce au contraire en
confiant cette infrastructure
aéroportuaire à des travailleurs à des
entrepreneurs à des actionnaires du
privé qui ont tout à perdre ou tout à
gagner selon la qualité la
responsabilité et la diligence dont ils
font preuve
elle est là la seule question qui
devrait nous occuper pour préjuger de
leur unité d'une privatisation
c'est la question budgétaire elle est
secondaire alors elle peut nous
préoccuper mais enfin si l'état avait
besoin de posséder une industrie pour
capter les revenus qui en découlent ça
se saurait la fiscalité est précisément
là pour permettre à l'état de récupérer
l'argent qu'il souhaite pour sur les
entreprises qui engrangent des bénéfices
donc c'est une question privatisé pour
plus de développement plus d'innovation
qu'est ce que vous répondez dominique
philias à la dans la réalité historique
je suis pas trop d'accord puisque depuis
donc le fait que adp dont groupe adp
passer en société anonyme
c'est une entreprise qui n'a pas arrêté
de se développer d'une part donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas nécessité de
changer ça même si le gouvernement a
toujours été majoritaires toute guérison
du coup sinon justement j'explique que
le motif avant on a on s'ouvre on disait
souvent oui il faut qu'une entreprise
soit privé pour qu'elle se développe
adp déjà privé donc pourquoi le
gouvernement va vendre ça veut dire que
ça veut dire qu'une tromperie sur la
formule privatiser partiellement privé
alors totalement non adp est une société
anonyme donc société anonyme avec les
conditions de la société anonyme gérée
comme une société anonyme
la différence c'est que les tailles
majoritaire pour l'instant à plus de 50%
l'étape garder son pouvoir de gestion
sur la politique de l'entreprise mais
perdre énormément sur les dividendes je
vous rappelle que ce sont les dividendes
qui sont distribués après avec les
prochains jeux olympiques et la coupe du
monde elle les dividendes pour être
honnête vont exploser c'est ce qu'on
espère pascal aéroports de paris
c'est la porte d'entrée à paris il ya
schajer l'aéroport d'orly et l'aéroport
de roissy
plus toutes les touches qui connecte ça
gère mes services sager les touches et
d'avions donc c'est énormément d'argent
je pense qu'il va venir alors pour
l'investisseur pour celui qui va acheter
des actions d'ici 3 4 ans c'est
peut-être ça d'ailleurs qui attirera le
futur actionnaire
on a ce projet de se dire c'est une
action qui va s'envoler ça alors
justement aberration aussi pourquoi le
gouvernement aujourd'hui va vendre ses
actions est ce que ça n'est pas
simplement parce que monsieur mac on
n'est pas sûr d'être là dans trois
quatre ans et n'en profiteraient pas
plus que c'est le gouvernement actuel
qui veut récupérer ses finances et pas
forcément celui d'après qu'il aurait
donc c'est une problématique complète
mais de dire qu'on veut privatiser pour
libérer pour permettre aéroports de
paris à se développer
pour moi c'est faux jusqu'à l'aéroport
de paris c'est
il a développé et a explosé a énormément
de filiales a investi dans beaucoup de
pays
d'ailleurs c'est presque le contraire il
semblerait même qu'il y ait des affaires
pas très très propre autour de tout ça
autour de certaines filiales avec des
gouvernements et avec des ententes sur
des projets et des finances peut-être un
peu au culte donc s est un terrain
intéressant pour qui en tout cas pour
s'opposer à cette privatisation le 13
juin dernier une mobilisation pour un
référendum a été lancé on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec dans le viseur les
fameuses 4,7 millions de soutien selon
le système imaginé en 2008 par nicolas
sarkozy on est aujourd'hui un plus d'un
million de signatures
un mois avant la fin de la procédure
après un départ en trombe aujourd'hui
elle sas night est ce que c'est un échec
programmé selon vous ce serait cette
demande de référendum
par contre si oui là je vais je vais
même être méchante je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs choses qui se sont passées
d'abord il me semble que monsieur macron
s'était engagé en avril 2019 a rabaissé
celle ce besoin de ce chiffre sur les
mobilisations à un million ils
l'auraient dû il alla il s'est engagé à
sargé pas de suite sur cet engagement
c'était la première chose qu'il voulait
faire et modifier aussi la possibilité
de référendum sur l'initiative donc de
la population et pas au contraire
d'autres initiatives
là j'ai pas de suite là dessus donc on
est dubitatif est ce que c'est un est ce
que ce sont des promesses
non tenues ou est-ce qu'il va se
manifester sur cette intention monsieur
mâcon on n'en sait rien ce qui est sûr
et ça pour être honnête ça a été
flagrant comment un gouvernement qui met
en place un référendum avec un outil
informatique et au lycée pour y avoir
été souvent et longtemps et avoir essayé
de comprendre pourquoi cet outil a eu
des bugs constamment les gens se sont
arrachés les cheveux pour pouvoir se
manifester
c'était d'une complexité et il n'y avait
que cet outil là entre guillemets pour
se manifester sur cette attention de
référente un fair game arrive vous
répondez dans un instant sur ce
référendum mais avant je vous propose
d'écouter alexis poulain il est
cofondateur du média le monde moderne et
pour lui rien n'a été fait pour aider à
la signature de la pétition je vous
propose de l'écouter on en reparle
tout est fait pour rendre la chose
compliquée donc effectivement concept
c'est énorme de signature avec en plus
une procédure compliquée on a vu au
début le site t1 compréhensible ne
fonctionnait pas aux fonctionnaires
enfin il a fallu expliquer avoir
vraiment des tutoriels pour comprendre
comment remplir le dossier
donc il y a une difficulté et puis le
temps aussi c'est à dire qu'il faut 4
millions en quelques mois donc c'est une
mobilisation de tous les jours ça
voudrait dire qu'il faudrait parler
davantage de ce référendum
quand vous avez le grand débat emmanuel
macron a eu d'un temps d'antenne
incroyable on parle de centaines
d'heures de télévision où il a pu comme
ça à évangéliser les foules
sentimentales française devant les
caméras pour le référendum on n'en parle
quasiment pas dans les grands médias
français
donc les gens qui sont courants sont
politisées ont déjà signé essaye
évidemment autour d'eux d'engranger
davantage de soutien mais que font les
médias qui les cache simplement cette
initiative et ils vont pas en parler
quotidiennement ont fait pas l'ouverture
du vingt heures il en avait aussi nié le
référendum adp aujourd'hui non on ne le
fait pas impérial asie harry justement
il aurait été important qui plus de
communication sur ce référendum vous le
souhaitez vous qui êtes favorable à la
privatisation des aéroports de paris
alors ça va faire dans le contre la
privatisation mais la prime était là
pourquoi pas alors un jeu démocratique
gauche aujourd hui face à après mon
sentiment c'est qu'en réalité le lait le
commun des mortels se s'en fiche un
petit peu c'est à dire que pour moi
c'est une agitation qui provient de
quelque parti politique qui soit par
pure opposition à la politique de macron
soit par anti capitalisme primaire parce
qu'ils ont tout faux pas digéré la chute
du mur de berlin sont encore des
nostalgiques de l'économie dirigée et à
chaque fois qu'ils entendent le mot
privatisation c'est un gros mot la
réalité c'est que je ne suis pas
convaincu que dans la vie enfin le
français moyen qui a autre chose à faire
de sa vie soit à ce conte très occupée
par la privatisation la non
privatisation de l'aéroport de paris
ceci dit vous savez la beauté d'une
économie de marché c'est que chacun est
libre d'investir et de de s'associer à
un projet entrepreneurial qu'il qu'il
affectionne donc si vraiment l'aéroport
de paris intéresse autant les militants
qui aujourd'hui craignent que cet
aéroport soit bradé aux premières
premier venu premier inconnu mais on
pourrait très bien imiter le modèle de
la fdj pourquoi ne pas simplement dire
mais tous ceux qui veulent être
propriétaire de l'aéroport de paris
avait 6 et acheter des actions cissé en
bourse ce sera quelque chose qui fasse
ce sera une opération qui sera facile à
à conclure et ceux qui sont indifférents
au sort de cet aéroport
il ya ce qu'il leur reste à l'écart et
ça montrera bien que finalement cette
équipe n'est pas aussi important et
stratégique qu'on le dit c'est à dire
que savait la notion de d'actifs
stratégiques c'est toujours très
subjectif c'est à dire que vous pouvez
très bien considéré que les aéroports de
paris
vous en foutez complètement et après
tout tant que c'est bien géré ça vous
importe peu de savoir à qui cet aéroport
appartient donc mon sentiment c'est que
les chefs de ce référendum est
d'ailleurs avec ses poulains le rappel
fait que s'explique par le fait que les
gens sont tout simplement indifférents à
cette opération
dominique il ya justement les gens s'en
fichent pour reprendre 15 de deux
aéroports de paris ou alors c'est
justement qu'il ya pas qu il y aurait
une volonté de ne pas communiquer sur le
sujet c'est quoi votre regard je suis
vous regardez un petit peu sur facebook
et d'autres outils vous apercevez qu'il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui se sont
manifestées sur cette problématique
il y a eu par exemple sur des places de
marché des individus qui sont installées
avec des spots pour aider il ya eu
certaines mairies certaines villes qui
ont mis à disposition d assistance des
outils pour les personnes pour celles
qui voulaient se manifester sauf que
effectivement et ça a été dit au niveau
de la communication des grands médias
il n'y a pas eu de communication des
grands médias comme y en a eu pour la
fdj
moi j'ai vu régulièrement et entendu
régulièrement de la communication là
dessus sur le référendum
il n'y a eu aucune ou pratiquement
aucune communication sur cette
problématique sur les grands médias sur
tf1 sur france 2 sur les journaux
télévisés
même sur les médias papier il y en a eu
très très peu donc avec un outil unique
qui est informatique que tout le monde
ne maîtrise pas avec des bugs constant
avec un lapin un laps de temps réduit et
nécessité d'obtenir un chiffre
il y en avait déjà effectivement qui
aurait voulu et qui n'ont pas pu se
manifester et vous verrez que nous
apercevrait d'ailleurs qu'on fait au
niveau de l'intérêt l'intérêt au lieu
d'être des croissants n'a été que
croissant surtout quand monsieur mâcon
s'est enfin exprimé à cette époque en
disant je réduirai
le besoin à un million d'euros là un
espoir et une renaissance sont revenus
attiser l'intérêt du public pour se
manifester
pour ce référendum rappelons que ce
référendum n'est pas pour décider contre
mais pour que les gens puissent
s'exprimer en ce qui concerne l'intérêt
du public
aussi si le public connaissait la valeur
financière de l'entreprise
si le public savait que les biens qui
ont été donnés à l'entreprise pour
qu'elle devienne sociétés anonymes
étaient des biens publics
si le public connaissait les dividendes
qui sont redistribuées avec les
investissements qui sont faites je pense
que le public s'intéresserait de la
gestion de cette entreprise et pour
s'intéresser à la gestion entre truc de
cette entreprise et il faut avoir des
axes des actions mais malheureusement il
faut aussi être décideurs ça n'est pas
parce qu'on a une action dans une
entreprise qu'on va avoir le pouvoir de
gérer cette entreprise alors dans les
années 80 on se souvient les
gouvernements de droite comme de gauche
ont lancé plusieurs vagues de
privatisation certaines comme les
autoroutes en 2006 ont laissé une trace
on peut le dire négatives dans l'opinion
à ce que justement il ya une crainte du
politique aujourd'hui que le l'opinion
finalement juge la privatisation d'avp
un peu à partir de ce ressenti là c'est
la privatisation de ces autoroutes et
moi je pense que la privatisation des
autoroutes au cal tout le scandale qu'on
a faits au tour a été un petit peu être
un peu comment dire un peu injustifiée
c'est à dire qu'on a reproché aux
autoroutes d'avoir la privatisation des
autoroutes d'avoir abouti à une
explosion des prix or il n'ya pas très
longtemps vos confrères de la presse
écrite du canard enchaîné ont révélé que
une autoroute à l'est de la france il
était entre les mains de l'état et qui
était complètement public pratiquer des
tarifs et une augmentation des tarifs
encore plus élevé donc ça montre bien
que bon le privé n'a pas le monopole si
vous voulez de la croissance des prix
c'est à dire que c'est des
investissements réalisés cda fera
structure a modernisé il est normal
aussi que cela se répercute sur sur les
prix sur les usagers maintenant moi je
remarque quand même une chose c'est que
on a beaucoup reproché notamment aux
autoroutes privatiser d'avoir supprimé
de l'emploi d'avoir automatisé notamment
mais c'est là le signe qu'une entreprise
privée est soumise à une discipline de
marché c'est à dire que mieux allouer
des facteurs de production automatisée
là où on peut automatiser pour gagner en
efficacité en efficience pour qu'ils
aient moins de fil pour qui est moins
que pour faire aussi des économies sur
la main d'oeuvre
c'est aussi là une infrastructure est à
swat est incité à faire preuve d'une
gestion plus rigoureuse donc en ce sens
c'est aussi une marque de succès
contrairement à ce qu'on entend dans
dominique filiale ça peut être une
crainte effectivement une privatisation
d'un des pertes d'emploi c'est quelque
chose que vous pouvez craint alors
pertes d'emplois de toute façon il ya
certains emplois qui resteront et
beaucoup d'emplois ont déjà disparu
parce que remplacé par l'informatique
par les machines par l'automatisation
par la reconnaissance faciale par etc
mais justement la privatisation n'a pas
empêché et n'empêche et ne changera rien
là dessus
la mutation des emplois de toute façon
se fait donc ça ne sert à rien de vendre
des actions pour dire que ça permettra
d'améliorer faire mieux alors oui on
peut faire mieux mais on n'est pas
obligé de vendre pourquoi vendre et
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire c'est le
gouvernement est déjà majoritaire qu'est
ce qui empêche le gouvernement on a un
ministère je crois savoir même qu'on a
un secrétaire d'état aux transports
qu'est ce qui empêche le secrétaire
d'état aux transports de d'améliorer les
conditions de vie et de transport dans
un aéroport en restant majoritaire
qu'est ce qui n'empêche rien ça n'est
qu'une question cette privatisation pour
nous pour moi mais pour beaucoup
d'autres
ça n'est qu'une question de finances
monsieur macron a besoin de mettre d'arc
de l'argent dans la caisse et il ya de
l'argent dans cette entreprise
on va le prendre maintenant parce que si
c'est pas maintenant ce sera le prochain
gouvernement qu'il le fera point barre
justement il reste un peu moins
de deux minutes on n'a pas tellement
entendu l'exécutif on l'entend beaucoup
moins sur la privatisation de la dpc
derniers temps est-ce que selon vous la
privatisation d'un dp se fera sous l'ère
des manuels macron pour l'instant il n'y
a rien qui montrent que ce processus va
être entravée c'est à dire que comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est quand même
finalement une opération qui indiffère
pas mal les français et moi je ne suis
pas du tout en accord avec la grille de
lecture un peu complotistes d'alexis
plainte ou d'ailleurs qui lisait les
médias nous cache un média il a aussi
pour pour vendre et pour intéresser un
lectorat à 6,1 en jeu
comme celui d' adp ne passionne pas les
lakers ne sert à rien d'insister là
dessus et de faire la une sur un sujet
qui comme le montrent les chiffres ne
passionnent qu'une frange très politisée
de la france encore une fois c'est à
dire que le français moyen mon avis est
un peu indifférent à tout ce tapage
médiatique dominique philias le mot de
la fin pour répondre à ferghana ziari
oui alors si le français moyen est par
exemple la personne qui va au marché qui
aperçoit un stand où on parle
d'aéroports de paris qui vient
interroger pour comprendre ce qui se
passe et qui finalement signé au bout du
compte cette pétition en se faisant
aider parce que le matériel est un peu
compliqué si c'est ça ce que vous
appelez effectivement là la france au
front des moyennes
ben moi je trouve qu'elle s'est
intéressée à la problématique
puisqu'elle l'a fait merci beaucoup à
tous les deux merci dominique il ya je
rappelle que vous êtes ex chargé de
communication et ex-responsable syndical
sud aérien merci à vous faire gagnent à
10 arrive vous êtes chargé d'études pour
l'institut de recherches économiques et
fiscales
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition dans
cinq minutes
un nouveau play un nouveau point en
gardant complet sur l'actualité rester
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis venu ici pour essayer de plonger
à la limite de mes capacités
je n'aime pas le froid c'est un défi en
quelque sorte
essayez de plonger dans l'eau glacée dr
oh la vache ouais
ce type qui a battu le record du monde
il a fait une autre plongée à 75 m je
dois plongé à 76 3 2 un départ